from a gigantic panda may facing off
with mingzilla to deleted four town
scenes and a rival red panda cousin the
original version of pixar's turning red
was going to be very different yupikai
movie lovers i'm jan and in this video
i'm revealing the alternate ending of
turning red and the incredible deleted
scenes and storylines you never got to
see spoilers ahead of course so take
care
one of the most spectacular moments in
turning red is when ming's red panda
form is finally revealed she's cute i
told you she was big that big despite
panda may's tiny size in comparison
she's still able to knock mingzilla out
however this final face-off was
originally going to be quite different
with a giant red panda may going up
against her mother in a godzilla vs king
kong style clash in the first draft of
the story maelyn's red panda grew and
shrank in size depending on how
emotional she got and the idea was that
by the very end mae would get so angry
with their mother that she'd become
similarly gigantic what would have led
to mei's massive monster-sized emotions
was as in the final film ming utterly
humiliating her in front of her beloved
boy band after already having
embarrassed her daughter in front of her
classmates at school and the store you
are in big trouble young lady the two
ginormous pandas would have then gone on
to fight in the streets of toronto in an
epic kaiju-esque battle the problem
however was that when the filmmakers
presented their idea there were lots of
questions about why mei would grow to
such a size and coming up with
consistent rules as to how or why she'd
grow to different sizes at different
times ended up being too complicated and
confusing in the end the filmmakers
decided to simplify mei's transformation
so that she simply poofed into a
single-sized panda regardless of the
level of her emotions which perhaps made
ming's transformation into the
absolutely humongous mingzilla even more
surprising given we'd only seen may's
panda up until that point by the way the
art of turning red book also has an
interesting storyboard of another
deleted version of the ending where a
helicopter news reporter can be seen
reporting on the panda showdown in the
streets below followed by a shot of
mingzilla grabbing pandamailin and
getting ready to spank her possibly for
the twerking show she put on
also in the book is a version of may's
panda where she appears to have what's
called fire fur the ability to conjure
fire whenever she's angry which you can
see also in this concept art of mayzilla
squaring off against her mother with
fiery red paws a little of this fiery
design might have ended up in the look
of ming's panda with her spiky almost
flame-like tail
turning red director domi she has said
that there were eight different versions
of the story before they settled on the
final one and in another early draft
ming was actually pleased about mei's
ability to turn into a red panda because
the panda was a good luck charm for the
temple in this version ming turned panda
may into a tourist attraction for the
shrine that she could monetize by having
her pose for pictures and put up with
other stuff like being a therapy red
panda some aspects of this did end up in
the final film when after the
destruction of the sky dome panda may
uses her new found fame to help raise
fans for its reconstruction and of
course in the main part of the movie may
uses her panda at school to raise money
for tickets to see for town according to
xi the first version of the movie was
really kooky and a goofy screwball kind
of comedy that featured a villain by the
name of benny blacktooth benny was a
gangster in chinatown who was trying to
take over the temple when it started
running out of money but they later
realised the story was getting far too
complicated and veering away from its
core which was a fantastical tale about
adolescence there's an interesting clip
in the turning red trailer which didn't
make it into the final movie of maelyn
and her friends marching through school
with placards a megaphone and a little
drum protesting environmental issues
disney's documentary about the making of
the film also has footage of the girls
falling to the floor as part of the
protest with the other students looking
on
the art of turning red book also has
designs of may holding up banners that
read respect your mother earth and hen
should be free and there's another
deleted scene of may watching tv with
miriam priya and abby and then declaring
her sudden love for boy band 4 town i
didn't even like four town last year but
now they're literally the greatest thing
that's ever happened to me another
deleted storyline had panda may
officiating at a wedding but just before
that i want to thank this video sponsor
fetch rewards an incredibly easy to use
free app that gives you rewards on
everything you buy it doesn't matter
what you purchase or where you shop you
too can make out like a money making
panda just grab your receipts and start
scanning to earn points in just a few
seconds any receipts will work from
walmart to ones to your local farmers
market or from even just filling up with
gas there's hundreds of different types
of rewards you can claim with your
points from amazon and visa gift cards
to free movie tickets at your local
theater vouchers for your favorite
restaurants and fashion retailers thanks
to my opening bonus and just the few
receipts i've scanned so far i can
already get one of these annual magazine
subscriptions completely free you can
also get rewards for your online
shopping like amazon and if you tap my
link in the video description and use
the code flix you'll get three thousand
bonus points for free many thanks again
to fetch for sponsoring this video
according to the artist this early
concept art shows a chinese mafia
wedding which i think means it was part
of the benny blacktooth gangster
storyline this makes sense given all the
dark suited types hanging around the
banquet hall it's curious that despite
the elaborate setup there's no guess and
it looks like there are some beads of
sweat on mae's forehead like she's
especially nervous plus the bride does
not look happy at all another intriguing
detail is the two merfolk and tanks on
either side of the bride and groom
in another iteration of the story there
was a rivalry and generational family
feud between the lees and mae's cousin
and aunt who could both also turn into
pandas in that version grandma also died
and may met her extended family at the
funeral that storyline was scrapped
because it ended up becoming too plot
focused and complex rather than
centering on the experience of a young
girl growing up although we did of
course see maelyn's drawings of devon in
her notebook there's several other pages
we never got to see when may ripped them
up after her mum embarrassed her at the
daisy mart pixar however have released
the sketches from the whole notebook
online which reveal extra pages such as
one with devon as a centaur possibly a
nod to onward and another of may and her
three friends dress like the protagonist
from the hit anime series sailor moon
domi she has talked about the influence
of sailor moon on turning red including
the pastels and the dreaminess of the
nightscapes and some early concept art
reveals some more deleted sailor moon
easter eggs such as this one on the wall
of may's bedroom there's also luigi and
toad from the super mario franchise in
this pic which didn't make it into the
final movie
another interesting detail in this early
concept art is that may's name was
originally faye i've not seen an
official explanation given for the name
change but it's quite possible it was
altered to avoid repeating the name of
the protagonist fei fei from netflix's
over the moon which was released in 2020
the title of the movie turning red has
numerous layers of meaning referring
both to may's literal discovery that she
can transform into a red panda a
metaphor also for an adolescent girl
getting her period for the first time
did the red peony bloom no
maybe and the sense of shame and
embarrassment that mae feels whenever
her overbearing mother intervenes in her
life outside home and her anger and
rebellion against that plus red is a
lucky color however as revealed in the
disney plus documentary there were also
a lot of different titles considered for
the story many of these were intriguing
puns such as notorious rpg red panda
girl a play on one of rapper biggie
smalls stage names the notorious b.i.g
my neighbor toronto a reference to
studio ghibli's my neighbor tutorial pms
panda mayhem story with pms also
standing for premenstrual syndrome and
mayhem also possibly being a play on
may's name red and redder is likely a
nod to the movie dumb and dumber red to
me probably refers to the expression
dead to me coincidentally also the title
of an awesome netflix series and these
ones here are another example of may's
original name faye
some other fun deleted scenes in the art
of turning red book include this one of
may in her den under the bed relaxing to
music red panda may and friends reading
at a store or library in this scene we
see that may's favorite boy band was
called boys inn streets likely a mashup
of boys to men and the backstreet boys
there was also a scene of ming and may
crying while watching a movie or tv show
and this piece makes me wonder whether
may had a baby sibling in another
version and then there was an extra a113
easter egg in the sky dome stadium that
wasn't in the final film there's even
more amazing concept art from the movie
in the art of turning red book so i'll
add a link below for where you can get
the book with free worldwide shipping i
really loved the finished film but do
you wish any of these scenes or
alternate storylines have been included
let me know in the comments below next
tap left to discover all the secret
symbolism and clues to the ending hidden
in turning red and if you enjoyed this
video then do leave a thumbs up i really
appreciate it thanks for enjoying this
movie with me and hope you have a
marvellous movie loving week yo movie
lovers